le problème qui se pose c'est que moi ce
que j'ai vu danser dans ces deux des
balades avant-hier sur ton émission que
j'ai vu c'est quoi j'ai vu d'un côté
l'avocat de booba qui vient poser les
choses en termes juridiques expliquer
quels sont les problèmes qui se posent
j'ai vu de l'autre une jeune femme une
influence euse qui finalement
est patron d'une agence qui
effectivement tout à fait et qui vient
d'expliquer qu'elle a créé un métier
toutes pièces dont elle ignorait tout de
celui ci puisque forcément il n'existait
pas et qu' elle a peut-être fait des
erreurs mais c'est de bonne foi bah oui
mais s'il fait des erreurs elle consiste
en des pratiques commerciales trompeuses
ou dans les escroqueries s'appelle pas
désolé
qu'est ce qu'elle va dire voilà dit que
s'il y avait eu des erreurs et qu'il
fallait qu'à 20 pays non ces cancers
il faut
savoir il faut redescendre sur terre
quand même abandonné je peux arriver
lire sur un plateau télé excuse-moi
gâche pas payer mes impôts parce que je
sais pas que ça et je les paye mais tu
comprends c'est pas de ma faute je suis
désolé s'il ya payer les impôts je les
paye non c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe bien abandonnée elle était
responsable